ukraine was one of those countries that
emerged from the breakup of the soviet
union now it's fighting to expel russian
invaders this morning a team of
international inspectors is headed to a
nuclear plant that is in russian
occupied territory amid concerns about a
potential disaster debra patter was
there when the team from the
international atomic energy agency
departed from keefe
director rafael grassi and his team
prepare for the early morning drive to
the russian occupied nuclear power plant
amid safety concerns along the route
we're going to occupy territory and this
requires
the explicit
guarantees from not only from the
russian malaysia also from the republic
of ukraine and we have been able to
secure that the plan sits along a
perilous front line where fighting has
heightened fears of a radiation disaster
the energy inspectors are on their way
to zaparisia it's a risky journey the
first time the body will be
investigating a nuclear plant in an
occupied war zone
the team will spend a few days at the
site in an attempt to stabilize the
situation
the nuclear inspectors met with
ukrainian government officials yesterday
including energy minister german
khaloshenko who told cbs news they made
it clear the russian occupation of the
plant has to end the station should be
back to ukrainian control ukraine
government control and then we could
implement any recommendations
grossi confirmed they hope to establish
a permanent presence at the power plant
for cbs mornings
parakeev ukraine